you or someone you care about may have
been diagnosed with bladder cancer
this video will help you understand more
about bladder cancer and how it affects
your body
your bladder is a hollow muscular organ
it stores urine made by your kidneys
from the kidneys urine travels through
tubes called ureters
to reach your bladder
from the bladder urine passes out of
your body through another tube called
the urethra
the tissue lining the inside of your
bladder is called Ural thallium or
transitional epithelium the most common
type of bladder cancer called uro thelia
carcinoma or transitional cell carcinoma
begins in this layer here normal cells
change into abnormal cells called cancer
cells over time these cells can grow out
of control and form a cluster called a
tumor there are two types of uro thelia
or transitional cell carcinomas based on
how they grow a papal Airy carcinoma
grows in toward the hollow center of the
bladder and a flat carcinoma does not
grow in toward the center flat tumors
are much less common but they are more
likely to spread deeper into the bladder
wall
bladder cancer may have the following
symptoms blood in your urine feeling an
urgent need to urinate having to urinate
more often pain while urinating
straining to urinate and lower back pain
it's important to know that other health
problems may cause these symptoms as
well cancer staging is the process where
your doctor figures out if your cancer
has spread and if so how far stage 0
refers to either a papillary carcinoma
or flat carcinoma in situ you that is
only on the surface of the inner lining
of your bladder this means it hasn't
spread into your bladder wall in stage 1
the tumor has grown deeper into the
lining but not into the muscle layer in
stage 2 the tumor has invaded into the
muscle layer in stage 3 the tumor has
grown through the muscle layer of your
bladder wall and may have spread to
nearby organs and lymph nodes
finally in stage 4 the tumor has spread
to any of the following the wall of your
pelvis or abdomen or to at least one set
of distant lymph nodes or a distant
organ such as your liver or lungs
a number of risk factors may raise your
risk of bladder cancer the most
important risk factor is smoking other
risk factors include having a personal
or family history of bladder cancer
exposure to certain chemicals in the
workplace past cancer treatments such as
radiation or anti-cancer drugs and
drinking water that contains high levels
of arsenic
as you deal with a diagnosis of bladder
cancer continue to talk to your doctor
and your cancer care team